hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel I'm here with another video
before I leave Australia for good and
get the out of this desert country
so today we are going to be talking
about eventual consistency and why it is
hard to deal with and some ways that we
can make life a little bit easier for
our clients when we have an application
that uses eventual consistency now
obviously the problem with eventual
consistency is of course that it is
eventual I can go ahead and tell you
guys that I'm eventually going to get a
girlfriend but in all likelihood and
frankly in reality that's probably going
to be between somewhere from 10 to 90
years from now so anyways let's go ahead
and jump into this we can talk about it
and see what we can do to make life a
little bit better for the people using
our application alright so I've got the
iPad up so let's go ahead and get into
things as you can see I've got this
handy dandy title making eventual
consistency less so if you recall
from last episode we often are going to
be doing things that are eventually
consistent the reason for this being
that strong consistency while nice is
too big the price to pay if I make a
right I don't want to have to wait for
that right to go to every single
database in my system I may have a
database in the US I may have a database
in Europe I may have one in Australia
and the penalty of having to wait for
that right to go to every single one of
those databases is just too big and
frankly not worth it so instead what we
end up doing is dealing with eventual
consistency where we write to one or two
or even a couple of places but we know
that some of those database replicas are
eventually going to get that right later
so with this in mind let's think of some
cool simple hacks that are going to make
life a lot easier for our user or the
client of our application so they're not
reading heinously and blatantly stale
data so example number one is just kind
of the base case of eventual consistency
recall that basically we've got one
client he's going to go ahead and make a
right to a database
he's going to receive an acknowledgment
from that database that the right has
gone through
and then he can go ahead and read from a
replica which effectively has no time
limits on when it's going to receive the
right it could come in in a day it could
come in a year who knows so he reads
that right he doesn't see his right from
before and now he's saying what the hell
I thought I just did something but it
turns out it didn't go through so let's
look at a few examples of things that
could happen when we're dealing with
eventual consistency and we're going to
go ahead and talk about these and uh
basically look at these cases and make
sure they don't happen and there are a
few easy ways of doing this so number
one is reading your own rights wouldn't
it be terrible if I and my girlfriend
who doesn't exist but it would be nice
if she did updated my relationship
status on Facebook you know this is uh
FB right here for Facebook and then of
course happen to read from a replica
right after which still went ahead and
told me that my status was single now my
girlfriend thinks that I'm snaking her
looking around for other girls to hook
up with in my spare time which frankly I
would and she thinks that I'm cheating
on her so obviously if we had strong
consistency this wouldn't be an issue I
would read from the replica and you know
it would say that I was in a
relationship
but one clever way of dealing with this
where we can still have eventual
consistency is we can say well for
starters if I'm going to make a right
for let's say you know 10 seconds after
I make this right I'm only going to read
from the database that I wrote to so
we're going to make sure that we get the
proper results back now our girlfriend
is happy and we can continue to cheat on
the DL no I'm just kidding but also what
we could do is even put a timestamp on
this right let's say I'm making this
right at time 100 I can look at another
replica let's say this one over here
before I make a read and say oh have you
seen rights from time 100 oh you have
well that means we can read from you
it's going to contain the fact that I am
in a relationship now if you've watched
my last series uh you know and you've
been on this channel for a while you
know that time stamps aren't really too
reliable when it comes to distributed
systems so there are a bunch of edge
cases where this won't work properly but
in the majority of cases it is good
enough to be right let's say 99 of the
time and you know save the time stamp
discussion for a future video
okay let's now go on to something called
monotonic rights or in this case the
lack thereof so let's say we've got one
group chat over here on the left where I
send three messages hey guys let's hang
out I'm free today and that has messages
ID one two and three respectively so
then my friend is going to come along
over here and read from these three
databases so basically let's imagine
that uh you know when you're reading
there's this button that says get last
message and you can just keep clicking
that and if there's a new message it'll
give it to you so effectively what guest
get last message does is let's say our
guy over here is going to first read
from a replica that has C in message
three and that's the last one it's seen
so first he's going to read I'm free
today which is great that's kind of what
we want we want to read from the most
up-to-date replica but then what's going
to happen is his next read where he
clicks get last message again because he
wants to see if there's anything new is
going to return message number two let's
hang out because that's the one with id2
and then finally he's going to do it one
more time for a replica that's only seen
message one as the last one and now he's
gonna see hey guys so effectively even
though it started out as if he had seen
all three of those messages what's
happening is our reads are effectively
going back in time and things are coming
in backwards because we're reading from
replicas that are progressively less
updated and that is obviously going to
be a pretty big problem so as you can
see I've written down the messages are
coming in in reverse order so what
actually is our fix here here well in
this case one easy thing that we could
do is actually have our user read off of
the same exact replica every single time
so even though the data that you might
be getting could be stale it's certainly
not going to be going back in time
because you're reading off the same
thing it's definitely going to be going
forward in time or as we might call this
a monotonic read so that's very
important to do how could we do this
well if you remember our modulo function
let's say our user ID is 20 we could do
20 mod 3 because there are three
replicas and that's going to be equal to
two so let's say this one is replica 2
over here we're always going to read
from that replica in particular so that
is going to simplify things for us a lot
obviously this has issues if one of
these replicas were to go down and of
course like all the things I'm saying in
this video because it's still pretty
overly simplistic there are a lot of
edge cases here however at least
thinking naively about this problem and
trying to get monotonic reads and writes
it's very important that basically you
know we're reading from the same replica
it can avoid this type of crappy
Behavior
okay then the last kind of edge case
that we want to talk about is actually
going over something known as consistent
prefix reads so for me to talk about
this I suppose the first thing we should
do is talk about something called
partitioning so partitioning is a topic
that I will be covering in depth on this
channel in probably five or six videos
but for now I'm going to make things
very simple let's say we've got one
database which is super big rather than
storing all the data in that one table
let's split it into two mini tables that
are on different computers so that's
going to be this guy and this guy and
let's assume now that we have two
messages basically one is me asking my
friend if he wants to grab lunch and the
other is the friend responding sure so
as you can see those are basically going
to two different partitions right the
arrows are pointing to two different
computers and the issue with that is
that each partition is going to have its
own separate replica so let's imagine
that we have a replica for partition two
which is this guy here and a replica
from partition one and because there's
no guarantees on when messages are going
to be transmitted over the network it's
possible that that message sure is going
to get to P2 replica before want to grab
lunch is going over to P1 replica and so
if that happens when person 3 the last
guy in our group chat goes and reads our
chat he's only going to see short and
he's going to say oh I wonder what that
was about I don't know and he's never
going to know that he actually could
have grabbed lunch with his other two
friends so how can we go ahead and fix a
problem like this well
basically what this is known as is a
causal dependency the only reason that
Shore was sent in the first place is
because it implicitly relies on the
sending of want to grab lunch now
obviously it's kind of tricky in terms
of how we can actually keep track of
these causal dependencies and for each
application that would be specific but
let's say that you know there was some
like reply feature in our application
you know a button that literally says
Reply and then the person wrote sure in
response to want to grab lunch what we
could do is say okay every time someone
uses the reply functionality to respond
to a message let's make sure that
they're actually go both going to the
same partition that way the messages
from that partition are going to be sent
in order to their replica and we won't
have to deal with any lack of consistent
prefix reads right this will allow us to
make sure that all causally dependent
rights are going to be on the same
replica which will solve our issue so
what's kind of the gist of this video
guys well it's not too complicated but
the point is this we are often going to
be dealing with eventual consistency now
that we've brought replication into the
picture and yes it is pretty much
impossible to completely get rid of any
sort of stale Reeds however there are
some sort of stale reads that are going
to make your user experience very bad
and very janky those examples are pretty
much the three that I covered in this
video and so as you can see there are
some clever solutions to basically
getting rid of the most blatant
violations of consistency right it's
always possible for example that if I'm
going to go to my Facebook news feed and
I'm going to say hey let me get a news
feed I'm not going to see all the most
up-to-date posts however that's not a
big deal because I don't know what the
most up-to-date posts are on the other
hand if I'm going to make a right to the
database and then five seconds later I
don't see it I'm going to be pissed off
so these three ways are kind of
loopholes and you know being clever to
make sure that your client of your
application is not getting too pissed
off due to the eventual consistency of
your application so in the next videos
I'm going to cover the specifics of in
replication topologies how you actually
want to basically send those rights from
one node to another in your databases
and once we do that we'll have a much
better sense of the entire picture of
replication and which type is right for
you anyways guys have a good one and I
will see you in the next video